हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो प्लीज बता दीजिए आई एम ऑडिबल टू
एवरीवन
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
क्लियर मेरी तरफ से वॉल्यूम सही है फुल
वॉल्यूम है और लास्ट क्लास में जो कंप्लेन
थी कि सर वॉल्यूम कम आ रहा है तो जहां तक
मुझे पता है मैंने बाद में चेक किया
प भी व थ्रू माय मोबाइल तो उसमें भी जब
फुल वॉल्यूम करते तो उसमें ऐसा कोई इशू
नहीं है कि वॉल्यूम डाउन है तो मे भी आपके
मोबाइल की तरफ से भी इशू हो सकता है दूसरा
अगर आपका इंटरनेट कनेक्शन का इशू होगा तब
भी वॉल्यूम का इशू हो सकता
है तो नेक्स्ट न मिनट में अभी स्टार्ट
करेंगे हमारी क्लास को तो जिनको जवाइन
करना है तो एक बार कर लेने दीजिए तो अभी
टाइम होने वाला है
बस ऑलरेडी 43 हो गए हैं तो मे भी एटलीस्ट
100 तो होने चाहिए लाइव
वाचिंग तो तब तक अग किसी कोई सवाल है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकता
है च सबसे पहले मुझे यह
बताइए कि लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको
बताया था कि काली नेक्स डाउनलोड करना
पैरेट ओस डाउनलोड करना एज पर योर
हार्डवेयर स्पेसिफिकेशन वीएम वेर डाउनलोड
करना और ट्राई हैक मी पर अकाउंट क्रिएट
करना और हैक द बॉक्स पे सब कुछ हो
गया मिर्जा टुडे टॉपिक इ ऑलरेडी मेंशन इन
डे टू पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
इन द अनाउंसमेंट सेक्शन वी ऑलरेडी कवर्स
ऑल द सिलेबस व्ट आई विल टीच इन दिस ल
जर्नी तो मे बी स्कल टन मेम्स मे बी नाउ
आई डोंट नीड टू एक्सप्लेन माय
कोर्स बिकॉज ऑलरेडी आई एक्सप्लेन इन
अनाउंसमेंट सेक्शन और यस्टरडे बिफोर डे वन
क्लास
नहीं काली नेक्स इज
वर्किंग तो मुझे एक चीज और बताइए सबने
काली नेक्स इंस्टॉल कर लिया मतलब कि
डाउनलोड करने के बाद इंस्टॉल किसकिस ने
किया है काली नेक्स हो सकता है या पैरेट
ओस या वीएम वेर किसी का कोई इशू आया और
अगर आप लोगों को नहीं पता है तो वीएम वेर
जो प्रो है वर्क स्टेशन प्रो है 17 फ्री
है सबको पता है डाउनलोड करना
अब
है चलो वी एमवेयर का बता देता हूं एक बार
आप लोगों को मैं डायरेक्टली आपको क्या
करना है गो टू गल वीएम वेर डाउनलोड एंड
सेकंड व वर्क स्शन प्रो नाउ अवेलेबल फ्री
फॉर पर्सनल यू
या य स्शन प्र डाउनलोड क्लिक ऑन थर्ड लिंक
एंड थर्ड लिंक के बजाय हम क्या
करते बैक चलते हैं गो बैक वीम वर्क स्टेशन
प्रो नाउ स्क्रोल डाउन स्क्रोल डाउन यहां
पर आपको डाउनलोड यह करना है वम वर्क स्शन
प्रो डाउनलोड क्लिक करना इस लिंक के ऊपर
नाउ उसके बादय आपको रिडक करेगा एक यह रहा
बड कम की एक वेबसाइट है तो यहां पर आपको
क्या करना है सबसे पहले अ यहां पर रजिस्टर
करना अपने आपको को सिंपली गो टू योर
रजिस्ट्रेशन और जो जो रिक्वायरमेंट है
नॉर्मल रजिस्ट्रेशन आपको कि अपनी ईमेल
आईडी के थ्रू इसको रजिस्टर कीजिए रजिस्टर
करने के बाद इसको लॉगिन करना है जैसे मैं
अभी लॉगिन कर देता हूं
वाइबर आईटी नॉट रिक्वायर्ड अगर अभी तक
आपने किया नहीं है अगर आपको अपने बेसिक
फंडामेंटल क्लियर करने है तो यू मे चाहो
तो आप बाद में कर सकते हो
मयंक तिवारी ऑलरेडी जो हमारी बग बाउंट
सीरीज चल रही है वह वेब एप्लीकेशन पन
टेस्टिंग सिखा रही है अभी वेब एप्लीकेशन
पन टेस्टिंग वही
है अगर आपके लिए वेब एप्लीकेशन की अगर
डेफिनेशन अलग है
तो फिर बात अलग
है बट इन द हमारे बीच में जो जो अटैक से
रिलेटेड बात आएगी कोई भी अटैक होगा अगर
वहां पर व वेब अटैक तो हम वेब अटैक करके
ही अगर फर्द एक्सप्लोइटेशन
करेंगे भरत जी आईम
फाइन कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है वर्चुअल बॉक्स
में तो यहां पर सिंपली आपको क्या करना
लॉगइन करना है लॉग इन करने के बावजूद आपको
वीएम वर्कस्टेशन प्रो 7 पर्सनल यूज यहां
पर क्लिक करना है देन यहां पर य वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक है पर तो सिंपली क्लिक एंड आपकी
फाइल डाउनलोड होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगी ओके
यहां पर देखो अभी प्रोडक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन
ओके विंडोज यह रहा दिस
वन बिल नंबर इंफॉर्मेशन एमडी
फ कौने मेगा गया यार
यह रहा य पर ऑप्शन है
वेट य पर अनक्लिकेबल इशू आ रहा है तो मैं
भी समथिंग क् मेरे पास ऑलरेडी पहले से है
तो मैंने अभी इंस्टॉल नहीं किया इसको
फिर से मुझे लॉगिन करना होगा
या आई विल चेक
अबे देखिए मेरा काम है आपको मल्टीपल
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर ट्रेनिंग करवाना
प्रैक्टिस करवाना ओके अभी आपका काम है कि
आप किसके साथ कंफर्टेबल हो क्योंकि अगर आप
कोई भी एग्जाम दोगे खास कर के साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के एथिकल हैकिंग के या
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के तो वहां पर क्या
है कि जरूरी नहीं कि काली नेक्स मिलेगा
आपको वहां पर पैरेट ओएस मैक्सिमम देखने को
मिलता है फिर आप वहां कंफ्यूज होगे सर
हमने तो ट्रेनिंग कालीन के साथ किया लेकिन
काली के पैरेट ओस प कैसे करेंगे तो इसलिए
हम दोनों मशीन को बीच में स्विच करके
करेंगे कभी पैरेट प ट्रेनिंग करेंगे कभी
काली पे करेंगे ऐसा कुछ नहीं कि व
स्पेसिफिक आप चाहो जिसके साथ कंफर्टेबल आप
कर सकते हो मेरी तरफ से कोई रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है कि आपको पैरेट भी करना है और खाली
भी करना है मैं दोनों ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
यूज करके दिखाऊंगा आपके सामने मैं फिर से
एक बार वीएमवी डाउनलोड प जाता हूं आई
स्किप सम स्टेप मे
भी कोई इशू नहीं है
यस यू कैन डाउनलोड स्क्रीनिंग रिक्वायर्ड
र यस प्रिपेयर फर डाउनलो फाइल एडिशनल वे
रिक्वायर्ड प्रोसीड तो यहां से आप उसको
डाउनलोड कर सकते हो ओके
तो आई होप कि य यहां से आगे आप कर सकते हो
बताने की मुझे जरूरत नहीं है तो हो जाएगा
और उसके बाद जो काली नेक्स है एक बार आप v
एमवे इंस्टॉल कर लोगे आपको आता होगा तो या
वर्चुअल बॉक्स आपके पास है तो वेरी वेल
आपको पहले से आपके पास अगर कोई भी मशीन है
काली नेक्स या पटस है तो आपको दोबारा से
उसको रीइंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं है
सिंपली आपको अपडेट करना है दूसरा आपको
क्या करना है कि यह तो मैंने आपको बता
दिया नो मैं इसको लॉग आउट कर देता हूं एक
बार क्योंकि लैब सेटअप जरूरी है अभी
धीरे-धीरे हम प्रैक्टिकल भी करेंगे तो
नेक्स्ट आपको क्या करना है गो टू माय आवर
[संगीत]
youtube0
काली यह रहा
वेट वेट वेट इसकी जो सबसे फर्स्ट वाली य
रहा इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस जो नितेश सर ने
कवर किया हुआ है कि कालीन 20 23.2 कंप्लीट
स्टेप बाय स्टेप इंस्टॉलेशन तो आप सिंपली
क्या कर सकते
हो इस वाली वीडियो के देख के आप अपना काली
नक्स को इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं जो फर्स्ट
टाइम इंस्टॉल कर रहे हैं जो फर्स्ट टाइम
यूजर्स हैं ओके तो आई होप कि यह जो लैब
सेटअप पार्ट आपका हो जाना चाहिए तो जो भी
कंफर्टेबल है चाहे वो काली के साथ या
पैरेट ओस के साथ तो प्लीज वर्चुअल बॉक्स
में या वीए वर्क स्शन प्र में इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिए क्योंकि अ जब भी प्रैक्टिकल्स होंगे
तो प्लीज डोंट गिव मी एक्सक्यूज कि सर
हमारी लैब सेटअप नहीं हुई है ये नहीं हुई
क्योंकि साथ के साथ मैंने आपको बता दिया
कौन-कौन से स्टेप परफॉर्म करने हैं फिर भी
अगर आप कहीं पर स्टक हो रहे हो तो मैं आप
लोगों को बीच में गाइड करता रहूंगा कि
क्या इशू है तो आई होप कि मुझे पता है कि
जो का की इंस्टॉलेशन वाली जो वीडियो है
प्लस में जो वीएम वेर है वीम वेर तो
बिल्कुल इजी है सिंपली क्लिक करोगे
इंस्टॉल करोगे इंस्टॉल ल नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
करते करते फिनिश कर दो तो आपका वीएम वेर
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा तो हो जाएगा य
तक नहीं नटू में नहीं कर सकते नटू में कर
सकते हो लेकिन आपको हर एक टूल इंस्टॉल
करना होगा खुद से फिर
तो अभी स्टार्ट
करें ओके चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं
हमारे तो
अगेन वेलकम टू डेनिक्स अकेडमी
फ्रॉम माय साइड और माय टीम साइड तो आज का
जो हमारा टॉपिक है वह है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग कि लास्ट क्लास में हमने पढ़ा था
कि फेजस ऑफ इ पेन टेस्टिंग कौन कन से होते
हैं सीआई ट्राइड के बारे में पढ़ा था तो
अब दि द फर्स्ट स्टेप इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
इसके बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं देखो
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इज द फर्स्ट स्टेप ऑफ
एनी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग और एथिकल हैकिंग
सारी की सारी लाइन सेल्फ एक्सप्लेनेटरी है
इट इवॉल्व गैदरिंग और कलेक्शन ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट एन इंडिविजुअल कंपनी
वेबसाइट और सिस्टम दैट यू आर टारगेटिंग
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग स्टेप के दौरान आप क्या करते हो
किसी भी कंपनी के बारे में किसी भी
वेबसाइट के बारे में किसी भी सिस्टम के
बारे में या किसी भी इंडिविजुअल पर्सन के
बारे में जो जिसको आपने टारगेट किया है
उसके के इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करते हो आप
कलेक्ट करते हो कहां सर ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस का यूज करके ओपनली जो पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल है इंटरनेट के ऊपर फॉर एग्जांपल
अभी समझते हैं यह कंपनी है कि दिस कंपनी
इज हायड यू टू परफॉर्म ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग ऑन देर वेबसाइट फॉर एग्जांपल यह
कंपनी है यह कंपनी आपको क्या करती है एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हायर करती है तो यू नो
वेरी वेल ड्यूरिंग द फर्स्ट फेज ऑफ
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
व्च इज इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग व्हाट इज योर
ऑब्जेक्टिव तो सिंपल योर ऑब्जेक्टिव विल
बी लर्न मोर अबाउट द वेबसाइट ऑन व्हिच यू
आर परफॉर्मिंग पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग ओके
सिंपली मतलब आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है कि
उस वेबसाइट के बारे में ज्यादा से ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करना व्हाट टाइप ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन
वी नीड टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
[संगीत]
उनसे वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है तीसरी चीज
जिस भी सर्वर उसको होस्ट किया गया है उसका
आईपी एड्रेस क्या है समझ पा रहे हो
वेबसाइट का आईपी एड्रेस क्या है तोय सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन जब यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपके
पास होंगी जिस भी वेबसाइट को आप टारगेट कर
रहे हो तो आपके पास एक पाथ होगा आगे बढ़ने
के लिए ओके तो नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते
हैं अनदर
एग्जांपल फॉर एग्जांपल यू हैव बन
कांट्रैक्टेड टू परफॉर्म ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्ट फॉर ए कंपनी एंड दे हैव यू गिवन ए
स्कोप ट यू कैन टारगेट ए फ्यू पब्लिक
फेसिंग एसेट्स लाइक वेब सर्वर एंड कपल ऑफ
इंटरनल सिस्टम्स विद इन द इंटरनल नेटवर्क
बेसिकली यह कंपनी है यह कंपनी भी आपको
क्या करती है एक कांट्रैक्ट पर एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हायर करती है ओके और आप
जब यह कंपनी आपको हायर करती करती है और
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के लिए आपका परमिशन
देती है तो आपके लिए एक स्कोप डिफाइन करती
है कि आप जो पब्लिक फेसिंग जो वेब सर्वर्स
है उसके ऊपर टेस्ट कर सकते हो या जो
इंटरनल नेटवर्क के इन इन सिस्टम या इन इन
आईपी एड्रेस पर क्या कर सकते हो
आप ट्राई कर सकते हो या पेन टेस्ट कर सकते
हो एंड यू है यू मे गेन एक्सेस टू द
इंटरनल नेटवर्क थ्रो पब्लिकली फेसिंग
एसेट्स लाइक वेब सर्वर ट मे बी वन अटैक
फैक्टर कहने का मतलब क्या है कि देखो एक
तो पब्लिक फेसिंग वेब सर्वर है जिसको क्या
है पब्लिकली एक्सेस किया जा सकता है
इंटरनेट से तो वन एक अटैक वेक्टर तो आपका
ये हो सकता है कि उसमें कोई वल्नरेबल है
उस वल्नरेबल के थ्रू आप क्या करोगे सिस्टम
के अंदर एंटर करोगे ठीक है आपने एक्सेस
गेन किया दूसरा क्या है अल्टरनेटिव
ड्यूरिंग द इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
स्टेप वी फाइंड आउट द एंप्लॉई दैट आर
वर्किंग फॉर द कंपनी अभी जब इंफॉर्मेशन
गेनिंग स्टेप परफॉर्म किया तो आपने एक
एंप्लॉई जो उस कंपनी का एंप्लॉय है उसके
बारे में कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन मिली एंड अब वो
इंफॉर्मेशन कुछ भी हो सकती है उसका नाम
डेट ऑफ बर्थ उसकी ईमेल ओके उस लाइक
डिसलाइक या क्या करता है कुछ भी
इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है ओके तो दिस इज द
मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट पीस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन इन द
कांटेक्ट वुड बी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन उस एंप्लॉई की हमारे लिए
सबसे हेल्पफुल इंफॉर्मेशन कौन सी हो सकती
है उसका नाम और उसकी ईमेल एड्रेस ओके यह
हो सकती है तो वई इट इज सो इंपोर्टेंट
अगेन फिर से एक सवाल है कि वो यह जो
ईमेल्स है या जो उसका नाम है एप्ल का जो
इस कंपनी का एंप्लॉई है इतना इंपोर्टेंट
क्यों है बिकॉज इंस्टेड ऑफ एक्सप्लोइटिंग
द वेब सर्वर इन ऑर्डर टू गेन एक्सेस टू
देयर इंटरनल नेटवर्क थ्रो प्राइवेट इज इजी
समझ पा क्या कहने कि अगर आपका वेब सर्वर
एक्सप्लोइटेबल नहीं है उसमें कोई भी वनटी
नहीं है तो फिर आपको क्या है कि एक्सेस
गेन करने के लिए इंटर नेटवर्क के अंदर
एप्ल की इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए ठीक है कोई
दूसरा तरीका अपनाना होगा या दूसरा कारण
क्या हो सकता है कि यह इजी पार्ट है इंटर
नेटवर्क में एक्सेस गेन करना कैसे वी
परफॉर्म ए फिसिंग अटैक और मिशिस अटैचमेंट
टू वन ऑफ द एंप्लॉय वाय ईमेल क्योंकि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करके या फेसिंग अटैक करके या
कोई भी मिलेश अटैचमेंट भेजकर उसको ईमेल
में हम क्या कर सकते हैं इंटरनल नेटवर्क
का एक्सेस ग्रांट कर सकते हैं प्राप्त कर
सकते हैं और जिसकी हेल्प से क्या है कि
हमें वेब सर्वर में भी वनटी ढूंढने की
बजाय हम डायरेक्टली एक्सेस कर लेंगे उसके
इंटर नेटवर्क के अंदर जब एक बार अटैकर्स
ने डायरेक्टली एक्सेस कर लिया इंटर
नेटवर्क को तो सोचिए कि कितना इज पार्ट हो
जाएगा तो इसी कारण से कहते हैं कि जो
फर्स्ट स्टेप है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का
जो कि इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है वह बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है वहीं पर अगर आपने
सही से उसको परफॉर्म नहीं किया तो मे भी
आपके चांसेस हो जाते हैं फर्द स्टेज ऑफ
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में या फर्द स्टेज ऑफ जो
फेज ऑफ पेन टेस्टिंग है उनके अंदर जाने के
लिए ओके तो यहां तक किसी का कोई डाउट है
तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
ओके तो मैं एक काम करूंगा बीच-बीच में
क्या है कि जब भी मैं कुछ स्लाइड्स है कुछ
भी टॉपिक आपको पढ़ा दूंगा उसके बाद मैं
आपसे डाउट लूंगा बीच में अगर कोई डाउट
होगा तो मैं पर क्लियर करूंगा अदर वाइज हम
एंड ऑफ द क्लास में लास्ट की फव मिनट में
अपने डाउट्स
लेंगे रिपीट
ओके देखिए रिपीट करने का मतलब मेरा क्या
है रिपीट करने के लिए बोल रहे हो आप देखो
एक कंपनी है आपको क्या करती है कि उसकी
वेबसाइट के ऊपर या उसका एक इंटरनल नेटवर्क
है जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल ये वेब सर्वर है
एक तो ये पब्लिक फेसिंग वेब सर्वर है
दूसरा एक खुद का एक इनका इंटरनल नेटवर्क
है जो क्या है कि आप इंटरनेट से एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकते तो आपको स्कोप डिफाइन किया
हुआ है कि आपको बताया गया है कि भैया आप
मैं या तो इस वेब सर्वर को टेस्ट कर सकते
हो दूसरा इंटरनल नेटवर्क में इन इन चीजों
को आप क्या कर सकते हो पेन टेस्ट कर सकते
हो अभी आपके पास क्या है कि इंटरनल
नेटवर्क को एक्सेस करने के लिए कुछ भी
सोर्स नहीं है एक ही सोर्स है जो कि वेब
सर्वर है ठीक है दूसरा क्या है कि जब आप
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे थे इंफ जब आप
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर रहे थे कंपनी के
बारे में उस वेबसाइट के बारे में तो आपको
एक इंफॉर्मेशन मिली एंप्लॉई जो कंपनी के
अंदर काम करता है ठीक है और उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन में क्या मिला उसके ईमेल
एड्रेस मिला ठीक है वो भी कंपनी का ईमेल
एड्रेस जो सिंपली जो अंदर नेटवर्क से
कनेक्टेड है इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड है और
डेली आता है एंप्लॉय और अपना काम करता है
तो हमने क्या किया कि चलो वेब सर्वर के
थ्रू हम एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे लेकिन
फेसिंग अटैक या सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक के
थ्रू हमने क्या किया उसको एक मिशिस
अटैचमेंट भेज दिया ईमेल में जैसे ही
एंप्लॉई ने उस परे क्लिक किया क्लिक करते
हम क्या कर गए इंटरनल नेटवर्क के अंदर
एंटर कर गया हमें एक्सेस मिल गया उसके बाद
हम फर्द क्या करेंगे एन्यूमरेशन करेंगे या
प्रिविलेज एलेशन करेंगे तो ये कहने का
मतलब मेरा कि दिस इज द पावर ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग
तो आगे
बढ़े इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कैसे करनी है सब
कुछ मैं सिखाऊंगा यह टिकल पार्ट है आपके
लिए सिनेरियो बेस है सब कुछ बताएंगे हम
ओके चलो
नेक्स्ट अभी इंफॉर्मेशन क द मोर
इंफॉर्मेशन यू हैव ऑन योर टारगेट
सक्सेसफुल यू विल बी ड्यूरिंग द लेटर
स्टेजेस ऑफ ए पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जितनी
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास होगी उतने ही
ज्यादा आपके सक्सेस होने के चांसेस बढ़
जाते हैं पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के अंदर
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इज ब्रोकन डाउन इनटू
टू टाइप्स जो आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है
उसको दो टाइप्स में डिवाइड किया गया है एक
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग और एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग अभ ध्यान से समझना कि
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग क्या होती है और
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग क्या होती है
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गदर क्या होता है कि इट
इवॉलवस गैदरिंग एज मच इंफॉर्मेशन एज
पॉसिबल विदाउट एक्टिवली इंगेजिंग विद द
टारगेट मतलब क्या है कि आप के पास एक
टारगेट है लेकिन आप टारगेट के साथ बिना
इंगेज किए बिना इंटरेक्ट किए चुपचाप जो भी
फ्री में उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती
है आपको किसी भी पर्सन के द्वारा वेबसाइट
से सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म से चाहे वो
लिंकन से मिले
उस टारगेट से बिना उसको इंटरेक्ट किए उनको
बिना पता चले वो आता आपका पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के अंदर ओके एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग क्या होती है इट
इवॉल्व गैदरिंग एज मच इंफॉर्मेशन एज
पॉसिबल बाय एक्टिवली इंगेजिंग विद द
टारगेट बाय एक्टिवली इंगेजिंग विद द
टारगेट फॉर दैट यू विल रिक्वायर ऑथराइजेशन
इन ऑर्डर टू परफॉर्म एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग देखो पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करने के बाद ही आप एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करते हो जब आपके पास प पैसिव में
मतलब बिना टारगेट से इंगेज की एक
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी उसी के बेस पर आप क्या
करते हो एक्टिवली मतलब उसके साथ इंटरेक्ट
करने की कोशिश करोगे एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में क्या आता है जैसे कि आप क्या
करोगे उसम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करोगे सर्विस
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करोगे आपका जो
आईपी एड्रेस है एक्टिव है या नहीं है और
यह सब करने के लिए जब आप किसी भी टारगेट
के साथ इंगेज होना चाहते हो तो आपको उसके
लिए प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए या तो अग बग
बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं वो आपको ऑलरेडी
ऑथराइज करते हैं क्या करना है क्या नहीं
करना दूसरा अगर आप बग बाउंट प्लेटफार्म को
यूज नहीं कर रहे किसी कंपनी की किसी स्कूल
की किसी कॉलेज की वेबसाइट को बिना वेबसाइट
को अगर आप क्या कर रहे हो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो आपके पास
उसका रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन होना चाहिए विदाउट
रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन आप मत करना वरना उसके
लॉग्स में आप डिटेक्ट हो जाओगे और वो आपके
अगेंस्ट एक्शन ले सकते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल
फ्रॉम पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेज वी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ऑन डॉट ऑन दैट आईपी एड्रेस टू
मिलता है अब आईपी एड्रेस के ऊपर हम फर्द
क्या करते हैं एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
कैसे करेंगे हम उसके ऊपर पोर्ट स्कैन करते
हैं जब हम पोर्ट स्कैन करेंगे और यह पता
लगाने की कोशिश करेंगे कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स
ओपन है कौन-कौन सी क्लोज है और जो पोर्ट्स
ओपन है उसके ऊपर कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रही
है तो ये सारी चीजें आती है आपकी एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के अंदर और डोंट वरी
ये सभी मैं प्रैक्टिकली आपको दिखाऊंगा तो
एंड वी कैन यूज ट इंफॉर्मेशन टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन गैदरिंग कंप्लीट कर लेते
हैं देन उसके ऊपर हम क्या करने हैं वनटी
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं
ओके स्टिल एनी
डाउट ओके नेक्स्ट चलते हैं अभी व्हाट टाइप
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर यू लुकिंग फॉर मतलब चलो
मैंने आपको बताया कि इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करने है लेकिन इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में भी
आप क्या है किस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन पे
ज्यादा फोकस करते
हैं जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मैं बता रहा हूं
इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग नहीं होती इससे
भी ज्यादा होती है बस यह क्या है कि ब्रॉड
कैटेगरी हैं तो पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
के दौरान आप आईपी एड्रेस के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं डीएनएस
इंफॉर्मेशन के बारे में डीएनएस के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन कले करते हैं डोमेन नेम्स
उसका ओनरशिप ईमेल एड्रेस अगर आपको मिलती
है सोशल मीडिया प्र प्रोफाइल्स कौन-कौन सी
वेब टेक्नोलॉजीज यूज की गई है या सब डोमेन
इंफॉर्मेशन ये सारी आप मोटी मोटी क्या
करते हो पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेस के
दौरान पता करते हो अब एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग फेज में क्या करते हो आप ओपन
पोर्ट्स फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हो
जो उसकी इंटरनल नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
है टारगेट नेटवर्क की उसको हम क्या करते
हो बेसिक रफ आईडिया लगाने की कोशिश करते
हो
मोर एमेशन न टारगेट सिस्टम और उसके ऊपर
फदर आप क्या करते हो स्कैनिंग और एमेशन
करते हो ओके नाउ अब बात करते हैं हम पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग जो पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है
सबसे पहले हम व पढ़ेंगे उसके बाद
हम जब एक बार पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का
थ्योरी कर लेंगे प्लस में प्रैक्टिकल
लेंगे नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हम पढ़ेंगे एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की तरफ ओके नाउ
अभी पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में सबसे
पहले हम बात करते हैं वेबसाइट रिकॉर्न एंड
फुटप्रिंटिंग
अभी आप लोग कंफ्यूजन होगा यह दोनों चीज
मैंने क्या लिखा तो आई विल एक्सप्लेन वी
आर गोइंग टू एक्सप्लोरिंग ए प्रोसेस ऑफ
परफॉर्मिंग ए पैसिव रिकस रिकस थोड़ा प्रोन
इ हो रहा है और पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
होने वेबसाइट ओके तो हम क्या करने की
कोशिश करेंगे से सेक्शन में कि हम पैसिव
फॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे किसी भी टारगेट
के ऊपर ओके तो व्हाट इ द डिफरेंस बिटवीन
फुट प्रिंटिंग एंड रिकॉन जो एक फुट
प्रिंटिंग है और एक रिकन में क्या डिफरेंस
है ज्यादा कोई डिफरेंस नहीं है तो बस जस्ट
मैंने एक इंटरनेट से एक डेफिनेशन उठाई
आपके सामने पुट अप कर दिया बाकी चीज दोनों
लगभग ही सेम है आपको कोई डिफरेंस देखने को
मिलेगा नहीं तो फुट प्रिंटिंग इज सेम
एज रिकन बट द ओनली डिफरेंस इज वी आर
आइडेंटिफिकेशन फॉर्मेशन दैट इज पर्टिनेंट
टू ए पर्टिकुलर टारगेट बेसिकली क्या है कि
आप फुट प्रिंटिंग में क्या करते हो कि
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट प ज्यादा फोकस करते हो
ठीक है बाकी चीजें वही है टेक्निक्स वही
है टूल्स वही है कुछ भी डिफरेंस नहीं है
ठीक है अब इंफॉर्मेशन फिर से आपको पता है
किस टाइप की आईपी
एड्रेस या जो डायरेक्टरीज छुपाई हुई है
वेबसाइट के अंदर नेम्स ईमेल एड्रेस फोन
नंबर्स फिजिकल एड्रेस वेब टेक्नोलॉजी
बीइंग यूज्ड ठीक है तो नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प
चलते हैं
अभी वेबसाइट फुट प्रिंटिंग कैसे करते हैं
ठीक है तो मैं आपको सारी चीजें बताऊंगा
थोट प्लस प्रैक्टिकल तो वेबसाइट फुट
प्रिंटिंग के अंदर क्या होता है देखो
वेबसाइट फूट प्रिंटिंग इज ए टेक्निक यूज
टू कलेक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन रिगार्डिंग टू द
टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन वेबसाइट समझ में आया
वेबसाइट फ्रूट प्रिंटिंग कैन प्रोवाइड
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
एसोसिएटेड विद द वेबसाइट सच एज रजिस्टर्ड
नेम
एंड एड्रेस ऑफ द डोमेन ओनर डोमेन नेम्स
होस्ट ऑफ द साइट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेल्स
आईपी डिटेल्स रजिस्ट्रार डिटेल्स ईमेल्स
फाइल नेम्स एक्सट्रा बेसिकली आप क्या करते
हो कि वेबसाइट फुट प्रिंटिंग के अंदर यह
वेबसाइट्स की जो इंफॉर्मेशन है इसका डोमेन
डोमेन ओनर कौन है किसने उसको रजिस्टर किया
है कहां से रजिस्टर किया गया है
रजिस्ट्रार की डिटेल्स क्या है वो वेबसाइट
को कब रजिस्टर किया गया कब उस एक्स हो रही
है उसका जो सर्टिफिकेट है ठीक है उसका
एड्रेस क्या है कोई फोन नंबर तो नहीं है
कोई ईमेल
तो एक्सपोज नहीं हो रही है यह सारी सेंसिट
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं हम वेबसाइट
फुट प्रिंटिंग के दौरान बाय परफॉर्मिंग
वेबसाइट फुटप्रिंटिंग यू कैन एक्स्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू द
टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन वेबसाइट जैसे कि च
सॉफ्टवेयर इज यूज्ड एंड द वर्जन ऑफ द
सॉफ्टवेयर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेल्स फाइल
नेम्स पाथ डेटाबेस फाइल नेम्स कांटेक्ट
डिटेल्स कंटेंट मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम सीएमएस
डिटेल्स खासकर जो वर्डप्रेस की वेबसाइट
रिलेटेड मिलती है द टेक्नोलॉजी यूज टू
बिल्ड द वेबसाइट स्क्रिप्टिंग एल्गोरिथम
मतलब जितने ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन वेबसाइट
रिलेटेड हमें मिल सकती है वह हम वेबसाइट
फुट प्रिंटिंग के अंदर करते हैं ठीक है यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करते हैं वेबसाइट
फुट प्रिंटिंग के दौरान फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं तो
आपको वेबसाइट फूट प्रिंटिंग से रिलेटेड
कोई डाउट
क्या कोई डाउट है तो
बताइए
यस नेक्स्ट
चले सीएमएस के बारे में बताऊंगा सीएमएस
में कैसे आप इफ गैदरिंग करते हो वर्डप्रेस
हो ग ये यह जो ऑलरेडी आपके पास क्या कि
सिंपली आपको क्या है कि टेंप्लेट सेलेक्ट
करनी है और आपको वेबसाइट प्री रेडी हो
जाती है उसको आप क्या कर सकते हो
रजिस्ट्रा कर सकते हो तो लाइक दैट की वर्ड
प्रेस
सीएमएस सब करेंगे हम
तो चलो नेक्स्ट चलते
हैं अभी बात करते हैं वज फुटप्रिंटिंग या
वज नमरे आप लोगों ने काफी सुना होगा वज
एन्यूमरेशन सबने सुना है
ओके कि एज ए प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर
यू शुड बी एबल टू परफॉर्म वज फुटप्रिंटिंग
ऑन द
टारगेट दिस मेथड प्रोवाइड टारगेट डोमेन
इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज ओनर इट्स रजिस्ट्रार
रजिस्ट्रेशन डिटेल्स नेम सर्वर कांटेक्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन एट्स बेसिकली सब कुछ वही है जो
वेबसाइट फुट प्रिंटिंग के दौरान मैंने
आपको बताया था वच एक टूल्स है एक
प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो आपका क्या करता है
देखिए यहां पे लिखा है दिस प्रोटोकॉल
लिसेंस टू रिक्वेस्ट ऑन पोर्ट
43 रीजनल इंटरनेट रजिस्ट्रा इज आर आई आरस
मेंटेन हुज डेटाबेस एंड कंटेंस द पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन ऑफ द डोमेन ओनर्स बेसिकली क्या
करता है कि वज एक ऐसा प्रोटोकॉल्स है
जिसके पास बहुत बड़ा डेटाबेस है वेबसाइट्स
की पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन का ओके तो जिससे हम
क्या करते हैं रिकॉर्ड्स को फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं इन द शॉर्ट वही है
कि इसमें भी हम यही पता करने की कोशिश
करते हैं कि वेबसाइट का ओनर कौन है कहां
से रजिस्टर हुई है किसने उसको रजिस्टर
किया है कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजी यूज की गई है
कोई कांटेक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन है कोई डोमेन ओनर
की डिटेल्स है अगर वह हाइड की गई ई हुई
होगी तो वह बात अलग है उसको कब क्रिएट
किया कब वो एक्सपायर होगी वह सारी चीजें
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव अगर इंफॉर्मेशन उसके मिल
पा रही है या नहीं मिल पा रही तो यह सारी
चीजें उस वॉइज फुटप्रिंटिंग के दौरान हमें
देखने को मिलेगी इन शॉर्ट इसका मतलब यही
है
ओके शॉर्ट में समझा शॉर्ट में ही समझा रहा
हूं यार इतना इजी कंटेंट ही मैं आप लोगों
के लिए डिलीवर कर रहा हूं इसमें शॉर्ट में
क्या समझाना है
वही मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि जो इसमें
लिखा उसको फिर मैं एक्सप्लेन भी साथ-साथ
में कर रहा हूं इन शॉर्ट वही है अब इसका
शॉर्ट क्या समझाना प्लीज
एक्सप्लेन ब्लैक गेमिंग
चलो अभी बात करते हैं हम गल हैकिंग और गल
डॉर्किंग सुना होगा कि
हमें गल डकिंग यूज करते हैं कई बार हम
मैक्सिमम टाइम किसी चीज को जब इंफॉर्मेशन
हमें नहीं मिल रही होती हम क्या ग डकिंग
का यूज करते हैं तो य चीज हो होती क्या है
इसको मैं क्या करूंगा जल्दी से आपको
समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं
google3 पहुंच जाएंगे देखो बिफोर
स्टार्टिंग द
[संगीत]
google.it एकटी और साइ m एक्सल फाइल जिनको
हम हर बार इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेस के
दौरान चेक करते हैं तो ये सारी चीजें हम
जब एक बार हमें पता चल जाएगा ये क्या होती
है उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे कि
वाइड वेब एंड प्रोवाइड द बेस्ट रिजल्ट इन
द फास्टेस्ट वे मतलब कहने का क्या है कि
जो सर्च इंजन है वो एक सॉफ्टवेयर
प्रोग्राम है जो क्या करता है कि जो डब्ड
है जो हमारी वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब है उस परे
क्या करता है इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या करता है
सर्च करता है फाइंड आउट करता है उसके बाद
जितना जल्दी हो सके उतना जल्दी आपको
फास्टेस्ट वे में आपके सामने रिजल्ट शो
करता है जैसे आप कई बार क्या करते हो सर्च
इंजन में कुछ भी कीबोर्ड इंसर्ट करते हो
कुछ भी कीवर्ड टेक्स्ट टाइप करते हो और
जैसे आप एंटर करते हो तो कुछ मिली सेकंड
में आपके सामने आंसर आ जाता है बिकॉज ऑफ
दैट यह एक सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम है अब ये
कैसे काम करता है मैं आपको बताऊंगा टू शो
दिस इंफॉर्मेशन सर्च इंजन डू ए लट ऑफ सॉरी
बैकग्राउंड वर्क अब यह सब करने के लिए जो
आपका सर्च इंजन है कुछ बैकग्राउंड काम
करता है वो कैसे काम करता है मैं आपको
बताऊंगा सो दैट वन यू क्लिक ऑन द सर्च बटन
यू आर प्रेजेंटेड विद ए सेट ऑफ प्रेसा इज
एंड क्वालिटी रिजल्ट दैट आंसर योर
क्वेश्चंस एंड क्वेरीज ओके तो दैट
बैकग्राउंड वर्क इज डिवाइडेड इन टू थ्री
मेन स्टेजेस जो यह बैकग्राउंड काम करता है
आपके रिजल्ट को शो करने के लिए उनको तीन
स्टेज में डिवाइड किया गया है क्रोलिम
इंडेक्सिंग एंड रैंकिंग ओके क्रोलिम
इंडेक्सिंग और रैंकिंग अब हमें जो मतलब है
समझने से वह है क्रोलिम से मतलब है ठीक है
क्रोलिम और इंडेक्सिंग रैंकिंग से कोई
मतलब नहीं है ओके अभी व्हाट इज कॉलिंग
कॉलिंग क्या है क्रॉलर इज आल्सो ए
सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम दैट आर रिस्पांसिबल
फॉर फाइंडिंग इंफॉर्मेशन दैट इज पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल ऑन द इंटरनेट अभी क्लोर भी क्लो
जो क्रॉलर है वो भी एक सॉफ्टवेयर
प्रोग्राम है वो भी क्या करता है जो
इंटरनेट पे जितनी वेबसाइट है जो भी
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन है उसको क्या
करता है फाइंड आउट करता है और फाइंड आउट
करके सर्च इंजन को दे देता है दज
प्रोग्राम स्कैन द वेबसाइट एंड क्रिएट ए
लिस्ट ऑफ ऑल वेबसाइट ओके अभी क्या करता है
पूरे वेब को स्कैम करता है अकेला एक
क्रॉलर नहीं है दे आर मल्टीपल कॉलर्स ठीक
है दे आर मल्टीपल सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम तो
ये क्या करते हैं पूरे वेब को स्कैन करते
हैं और एक लिस्ट बनाते हैं वेबसाइट की दे
विजिट ईच पेज ऑफ द वेबसाइट एंड स्कैन द
होल एचटीएमएल कोड एंड देन ट्राई टू
अंडरस्टैंड कि व्हाट इज द स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ द
पेज टाइप्स ऑफ कंटेंट्स दे आर यूजिंग
मीनिंग ऑफ द कंटेंट व्हेन इट वाज
अपडेटेड ओके नाउ लेट्स हाउ वेब क्रॉलर
क्रॉल द वेबसाइट एंड हाउ दे इंडेक्सिंग द
वेबसाइट अभी जो आप मैं आपको समझाता हूं इन
शॉर्ट में क्या होता है क्रॉलर सबसे पहली
बात क्रॉलर एक सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम है
क्लियर दूसरा क्या करता है कि पूरे वेब
कोय स्कैन करता है एक लिस्ट बनाता है
वेबसाइट की और वेबसाइट में क्या चेक करता
है कि जो जितना भी एचटीएमएल कोड लिखा है
सबको स्कैन करता है और वहां से कीवर्ड
उठाता है कीवर्ड कि कोई इमेज है इमेज का
कोई कीवर्ड उठाएगा इमेज नाम से इमेज का
कुछ भी कीवर्ड होगा फिर वेबसाइट के अंदर
कुछ कीवर्ड्स होंगे उनकी एक लिस्ट बनाएगा
ठीक है इंडेक्स के फॉर्म में और उस लिस्ट
को इस वेबसाइट के से रिलेटेड क्या कर देगा
आपके सर्च इंजन को फॉरवर्ड कर देगा चलो हम
इसको समझते हैं कि कैसे यह क्रॉल करता है
वेबसाइट
को द डायग्राम बिलो इज ए हाई लेवल
एब्स्ट्रेक्शन ऑफ हाउ दिस वेब क्रॉलर
वर्क्स ठीक है मैं आपको य पढ़ के नहीं
दिखाऊंगा सुनाऊंगा मैं आपको यह समझा देता
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल ये आपका सर्च इंजन है
इंजन है और आप जैसे ही सर्च इंजन में क्या
करते हो ये इसके पास एक क्रॉलर है सर्च
इंजन का ठीक है अब ये क्रॉलर क्या करता है
जोय पूरा वेब वेब है फॉर एग्जांपल ये एक
सर्वर है इसको क्या करता है पूरे को स्कैन
करता है अब एग्जांपल के तौर पर इसने स्कैन
किया यहां पर एक वेबसाइट है मा
website.com अब इसने क्या है कि इसके सारे
कंटेंट को क्या करेगा ये स्कैन करेगा
समझने की कोशिश करेगा समझ के फिर क्या
करेगा वहां से कीवर्ड जो भी कीवर्ड्स है
या इमेजेस हैं उनको रिकॉर्ड करेगा और उनके
लिस्ट बनाएगा जैसे यह माय वेबसाइट कॉ है
इसमें से इसने कीवर्ड फाइंड आउट किए एल
बनाना पीएस फॉर एग्जांपल कोई एक सेलर है
कुछ भी फ्रूट
सेलर सॉरी
गाइ सॉरी तो इसने कुछ कीवर्ड्स उठाए
वेबसाइट के अंदर से और उन कीवर्ड्स की एक
लिस्ट बनाई एक टेबल बनाई और उसको जो सर्च
इंजन है सर्च इंजन को फॉरवर्ड कर दिया और
सर्च इंजन क्या करता है अपने लोकल डेटाबेस
में उसको क्या कर लेगा स्टोर कर लेगा ठीक
है चलो नेक्स्ट अब यूजर क्या करता है फॉर
एग्जांपल ये यूजर है यूजर्स ने क्या किया
एक पियर्स नाम का एक कीवर्ड है देखिए यहां
पर जो हमने एल बनाना पीयर था अब सर्च इंजन
ने क्या किया कि पीएस नाम के कीवर्ड को
सर्च किया और सर्च इंजन जैसे सर्च किया तो
वो क्या करता है उस इंडेक्स को चेक करता
है तो सारे जो क्रॉल किया जो क्रॉल किए
हुए कीवर्ड्स है उनमें सब में क्या
इंडेक्स को सर्च करेगा इंडेक्स जहां-जहां
पर उसको पियर्स मिलेगा चाहे उस वहां पर एक
वेबसाइट हो इंडेक्सिंग के अंदर चाहे
मल्टीपल वेबसाइट हो सारी वेबसाइट में
जहां-जहां पर उसको यह कीवर्ड मिलेगा उसको
क्या कर देगा ये लिस्ट डाउन कर देगा आपके
सामने ये क्या क्या बैकग्राउंड में चेक
करेगा कि ओके अनदर website.com
इसके ओके कीवर्ड में पीयर्स है चलो एक अगर
कोई थर्ड वेबसाइट होगी तो उसमें उसमें भी
चेक करेगा कीवर्ड्स ओके पीयर्स है तो इस
तरीके से क्या करेगा कि जितनी भी वेबसाइट
है और हर एक वेबसाइट के अंदर जो ये कीवर्ड
मैच करेगा उसकी क्या करेगा एक लिस्ट आपके
सामने आ जाती है आपने कई बार देखा होगा कई
कोई भी एक कीवर्ड आप
एवरी यूआरएल एंड फाइल दैट दे कैन फाइंड बट
आल्सो हैड यूआरएल टू अनदर वेबसाइट कहने का
मतलब क्या है देखो फॉर एग्जांपल यह क्रॉलर
था क्रॉलर ने माय website.com को क्रॉल
किया उसके वेब कंटेंट को एचटीएमएल कोड को
जैसे उसको क्रोल किया तो इसको इसके अंदर
कुछ तो कीवर्ड तो मिल गए लेकिन उसके अंदर
क्या थे कुछ यूआरएल थे दूसरी वेबसाइट के
अनदर website.com तो क्या करेगा उस अनदर
website.com पर भी जाएगा उसके भी वेबसाइट
कंटेंट को क्या करेगा स्कैन करेगा उसकी भी
एक लिस्ट बनाएगा फॉर एग्जांपल टोमेटो
स्ट्रॉबेरी पाइनएप्पल्स ये लिस्ट उसने
बनाई और दोनों लिस्ट को क्या करेगा सीधा
डायरेक्टली सर्च इंजन को फॉरवर्ड कर देगा
कि बोलो यह वेबसाइट थी मा website.com
इसके अंदर एक तो कीवर्ड तीन कीवर्ड ये हैं
उसके अंदर एक यूआरएल था यूआरएल के अंदर भी
कीवर्ड थे ठीक है और उसकी एक लिस्ट बनाई
उन सारे कंटेंट को डायरेक्टली किसको भेज
देगा सर्च इंजन को सर्च इंजन क्या कर अपने
लोकल डेटाबेस में उसको स्टोर कर लेगा अब
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं तो इस तरीके
से जो आपका सर्च इंजन है उसके पास है कि
दो वेबसाइट की इंफॉर्मेशन मा website.com
कीवर्ड एल मा website.com बनाना मा
website.com पस इस तरीके से वो इंडेक्सिंग
करके रखते हैं अपने सर्वर के अंदर लोकल
डेटाबेस के अंदर और जैसे ही आप सर्च करते
हो कोई भी के हो जैसे आपने टोमेटो सर्च
किया तो सीध आपकी अनदर website.com का भी
रिजल्ट आपके सामने देखने को मिलेगा और अगर
और किसी वेबसाइट में भी यह कीवर्ड होगा तो
कीवर्ड आपके सामने रिजल्ट में शो होता
है तो इस तरीके से आपका जो वेब क्रॉलर है
वो काम करता है एवरीवन क्लियर स्टिल किसी
को कोई डाउट है यहां
पर मे भी मुझे लगता है कि किसी को डाउट
नहीं
आएगा ओके नोट सेंड करवा दूंगा
मैं चलो यह इंफॉर्मेशन थी आपकी किसके बारे
में वेब क्रॉलर के बारे में क्रॉलर के
बारे में अभी हम बात करते हैं एक रोबोट
डटी एक्सटी नाम की एक फाइल होती है जो
हमेशा आप इन पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के दौरान
चेक करोगे तो देखो दिस इज द हैकर्स फर्स्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप अब हमेशा जब
इंफॉर्मेशन गडिंग स्टेप करता है तो
robot.txt फाइल को हमेशा चेक करता है
क्यों क्या है robot.txt क्यों डेवलपर
उसको वेबसाइट में रखते हैं ठीक है और
क्यों ये इंपॉर्टेंट है देखिए आपको इस
तरीके से देखने को मिलेगी आपकी robot.txt
फाइल ये इंग्लिश को आप पढ़ लेना जो आपका
जो वेबसाइट है उसकी रूट डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
इस robot.txt फाइल को क्रॉल कर सकता है
उसके बाद कितना डिले मी मींस यहां पर क्या
है कि जो buzzfeed.com है जिसमें यह एमसन
बोट है वह
120 मिली सेकंड के लिए वेट करेगा इस
वेबसाइट को क्रॉल करने से पहले उसके बाद
क्या करेगा यहां पर लिखा डिस अलाव डिस
अलाव डिस अलाव मतलब क्या है कि जो
इंफॉर्मेशन है फ स्ड एक्सल एए यह बज
कैटेगरी मोबाइल ब यह य सारी की सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन
क्रॉलर को अलाव नहीं है क्रॉल करने के लिए
मतलब क्या करेगा कि यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन वो
इंडेक्स नहीं करेगा समझ पा रहे हो मतलब
क्या है कि यह कुछ इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
है वेबसाइट के लिए जो पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
नहीं है जिसको वेब क्रॉलर क्रॉल नहीं कर
सकता इसलिए क्या है इसको एक्सेस भी नहीं
कर सकते ठीक है तो इनको क्या कर सकते हो
आप डायरेक्टली
w.com फ प्लगइन फ इसको आप खुद से ट्राई
करके देखना है क्या यहां पर कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन या कोई वनटी तो
नहीं है जो हमेशा आप ट्राई करने की कोशिश
करते हो कि अलग डायरेक्टर के अंदर जाने की
कोशिश करते हो नेक्स्ट सेकंड पॉइंट वही है
यूजर एजेंट यहां पर स्टार मार्क्स मतलब
सभी जितने भी क्रॉलर है सबको अलाउड है
लेकिन यहां पर भी डिस अलाउ है मतलब ये
सारे कंटेंट को आप क्या नहीं कर सकते आप
क्रॉल नहीं कर सकते ऐसे ही डिस अलाव अगर
आप यहां पर अलाव लिखा है अलाउ की लिस्ट दी
हुई है मतलब क्या है कि जो अलाव है उन्हीं
लिस्ट को क्या कर सकते हो आप क्रॉल कर
सकते हो इस वेबसाइट के अंदर बाकी जो डिस
अलाव वाली चीजों को आप क्रॉल नहीं कर सकते
इंडेक्स नहीं कर सकते ग डेटाबेस के अंदर
एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि व्हाट डू वी मीन बाय
रोबट डटी एक्सटी
फाइल ओके नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं हम साइट
मैप्स साइट मैप इज ए फाइल दैट लिस्ट आउट द
यूआरएल ऑफ ऑल एसेंशियल पेजेस ऑफ योर
वेबसाइट बेसिकली क्या करते हैं कि आप जब
भी वेबसाइट डिजाइन करते हो उसका एक साइट
मैप तैयार करते हो ठीक है उसका क्या करते
हो एक साइट मैप तैयार करते हो और वह क्या
करते हो आप एक तो यूजर्स के लिए रखते हो
साइट मैप कि कौन सी मतलब अरेंज करके एक
क्या करते हो आप क्रोल के क्रॉलर के लिए
रखते हो ताकि कौन सी चीज किसके बाद
इंडेक्स होनी चाहिए ऐसे नहीं कुछ भी रैंडम
खुल जाए तो इसलिए उसका वो है साइट मैप दा
परपज इज टू हेल्प सर्च इंजन अंडरस्टैंड
योर साइट एंड लोकेट स्पेसिफिक पेजेस विद
इज फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे w example.com है तो
आपने देखा हो www.ab अस
ww.com कांटेक्ट अस ww.com कैटेगरी 1
प्रोडक्ट वन सब कटेगरी प्रोडक्ट टू इस
तरीके से इस तरीके से ये क्या है सारी ये
साइट मैप्स है इसी तरीके से आपके अरेंज की
जाती है ये सारी क्या है एक साइट मैप के
अंदर तैयार किया जाता है दो टाइप के साइट
मैप होते हैं एक तो एचटीएमएल साइट मैप
होता है एक एक्सएमएल साइट मैप होता है जो
एचटीएमएल साइट मैप होता है वो यूजर्स के
लिए होता है सो दैट इट कैन नेविगेट आवर
वेबसाइट स्मूथली और जो एक्सएमएल साइट मैप
होता है वो कॉलर्स के लिए होता है सो दैट
इट कैन अंडरस्टैंड द एजेक्ट स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ
द वेबसाइट वेबसाइट की एजेक्ट स्ट्रक्चर
क्या है ओके मुझे लगता है कि बग बाउंट के
अंदर यह चीज आपने शायद देखी भी होगी साइट
मैप ओपन करके कई इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन आप
देखने को मिलती भी है एवरीवन गट क्लियर
टिल नाउ कि व्हाट डू वी मीन बाय
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एंड पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
कह वेबसाइट फर प्रिंटिंग का मतलब क्या है
हु इज इंफॉर्मेशन एंड
ने कुछ स्लाइड से पता कर लिया समझ लिया
अभी डॉर्क क्या होता है डर्क इज बेसिकली अ
क्यूरी दैट यू सर्च और ए क्यूरी ऑपरेटर
मतलब बेसिकली क्या है कि डर्क एक क्यूरी
ऑपरेटर है या एक क्यूरी है जिसको आप क्या
करते हो सर्च करते हो अपने सर्च इंजन के
थ्रू आपने देखा हो जैसे ग का सर्च इंजन
उसमें हम कुछ भी लिखते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने लिखा
कि टॉप 10 मोबाइल फोनस तो ये क्या है एक
क्यूरी है क्यूरी है जो आप इसके अंदर क्या
करते हो सर्च इंजन के थ के अंदर इंसर्ट
करते हो टेक्स्ट करते हो उसके बाद सर्च
बटन हिट करते हो उसी के बेस पे आपको क्या
करती है इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है बेस्ड ऑन दैट
वी गेट आवर रिजल्ट्स आफ्टर ट्यूनिंग अप
आवर सर्च क्यूरी वी फाइंड सम सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन एज वेल व्हिच इज सेव्ड इन टू द
सर्वर बाय डेवलपर्स ओके जो सर्वर के
द्वारा सर्वर के अंदर डेवलपर के द्वारा
सेव की जाती है तो बेसिकली क्या है कि जो
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि जो चीज हम नॉर्मल
सर्च क्यूरी से फाइंड आउट नहीं कर सकते वह
हम
google2 ऑफ रिजल्ट्स आपको देखने को मिलते
हैं बट जब आप अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन को नैरो
डाउन करना चाहते हो स्पेसिफिक सर्च करना
चाहते हो तो उसमें आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
एडवांस
ग एडवांस सर्च तो दिस इज द योर अभी तक तीन
टॉपिक्स जो आज की क्लास में हमारे पास इन
तीनों को हम प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे तो
प्लीज ओके तो आई होप कि यहां तक सबको समझ
में आया होगा प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट हम सॉरी
थोट कल पार्ट तो अब इन तीनों चीजों को हम
क्या करेंगे अभी थ प्रैक्टिकल करने की
कोशिश करते हैं प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे
प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट पर
चले चलिए प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
प सब लोग एंजॉय कर रहे हो
ना यस श्यर नोट्स मिल जाएंगे आपको आज की
क्लास के पक्का नोट मिल जाएंगे
आपको ये कहां पर मिलेंगे आपको सबको पता है
देखिए आपके पास लैपटॉप्स नहीं है आपके पास
मशीन सेटअप नहीं कर
सकते तो व मैं कुछ नहीं कर
सकता वह जवा मेरे पास भी नहीं है आप लोगों
के
लिए उसके लिए मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता आई एम
नॉट रिस्पांसिबल मैं रिस्पांसिबल हूं
चीजें सिखाने के लिए अगर वोह सही से नहीं
सिखा रहा हूं तो उसके लिए मैं रिस्पांसिबल
हूं च सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं अपनी
काली नेक्स को ऑन करते
हैं आपको नोट्स मिलेंगे हमारे ट ग्रुप के
अंदर यहां पर फॉर एग्जांपल दिस यह हमारा
काली सीरीज है फॉर एग्जांपल तो कोई भी आप
ओपन करोगे फॉर एग्जांपल हम क्या करते हैं
डे फरस अकेडमी के अंदर जाते हैं उसके बाद
दिस इज अवर डे वन वे इ द डे वन डे वन के
अंदर भी होगा ओके ये अनाउंसमेंट सेक्शन है
मोर एंड जॉइन आवर
[संगीत]
कि आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास कब शेड्यूल होगी कब
नहीं होगी सर नोट्स कहां मिलेंगे ये इसका
रिसोर्सेस कहां मिलेंगे इस इस जगह के
अलावा आपको कहीं पर नहीं मिलेंगे तो आपको
यह जवाइन करना ही पड़ेगा इट इज वेरी
नेसेसरी कंपलसरी तभी आपको यह इंफॉर्मेशन
देखने को
मिलेगी मराज व्ट इज द इशू विद योर काली
नेक्स
चलो अभी मेरा काने ऑन हो रहा है
कौन सा वर्जन यूज कर रहे
हो आई डोंट नो यह कैसा सवाल है
यार विंडोज के लिए मैं बीएमवी प्रेफर
करूंगा वर्क स्टेशन प्रो वल वक्स में कई
बार ग्लिच आते
हैं मैकबुक के लिए वर्चुअल बॉक्स परफेक्ट
है
तो लाइव बूटेबल वाले बहुत मुश्किल से
अपडेट हो पाते हैं तो डोंट ट्राई टू
अपडेट अपग्रेड म मत कीजिए बस ओनली अपडेट
कीजिए अपडेट हो जाते हैं एपीडी गेट अपडेट
करके आप जो करोगे वह हो जाता है बट
अपग्रेड नहीं होगा तो दिस इज आवर काली
नेक्स मशीन तो हम आज से प्रैक्टिकल
स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं तो मैं थोड़ी देर के लिए आपकी चैट
नहीं
देखूंगा तो मैं व भी देख लेता हूं वेट
चलो तो
अभी अभी मैं क्या करता अपने वेब ब्राउजर
को ओपन करता हूं
तो एक बार जूम जूम कर देता हूं आप लोगों
के लिए
प्लस चलो सबको दिखाई दे रहा है स्क्रीन पर
फ एपल हमारे पास एक वेबसाइट है हमारी
वेबसाइट है
डेनिक्स कॉम मेरे पास एक वेबसाइट है और
मैंने क्या किया ट एंटर सिंपली मेरे पास
यह वेबसाइट है मेरा टारगेट यही है फॉर
एग्जांपल
तो अभी तक मेरे पास कॉ की कोई भी
इफॉर्म नहीं आई डोंट नो एनीथिंग अबाउट
डेनिक्स कॉ ओके देन व्हाट इज योर फर्स्ट
स्टेप कि व्ट विल यू डू विद दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन
दे ओनली वन डोमेन नेम फक्ड कॉम तो व्हाट
विल यू डू क्या करोगे आप
सभी सबसे पहला स्टेप आपका क्या
रहेगा एनी वन एनी आईडिया
अब्दुल वेरी गुड जो सबसे पहला स्टेप हमारा
रहेगा वह रहेगा आईपी एड्रेस पता करना
वेबसाइट का व्ट इज द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ दिस
वेबसाइट समझ पा रहे हो अभी आपको कुछ केसेस
में या बहुत सारे केसेस ऐसे होंगे जहां पर
आपको प्रोडक्ट वेबसाइट देखने को मिलेंगी
और अगर प्रोडक्शन वेबसाइट है तो वह आपकी
फायरवॉल या प्रॉक्सी के पीछे हाइड मिलेंगी
छुपी हु मिलेंगी समझ पा रहे
हो जैसे की क्लाउड फेयर सर्विस को यूज कर
रहे होंगे तो उस तरीके से तो चलो अभी मैं
आईपी की इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे फाइंड आउट करता
हूं आपके सामने उसके लिए एक टूल होता है
आईपी के लिए ठीक है व हम क्या कर सकते हैं
एक टूल होता हमारे पास होस्ट टूल का नाम
सुना है होस्ट होस्ट
एक हमारा होस्ट टूल
है एक
मिनट यार क्या इशू
है ई टू
वेट मुझे ब इसको सेट कर देता हूं
मैं चलो एक बार शिफ्ट प्लस प्लस
प्लस चलो ओनली
वन शायद आपको सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा
होगा
एक होस्ट कमांड होती है होस्ट हिट एंटर ये
होस्ट कमांड होती है अभी मुझे नहीं पता ये
कमांड क्या होती है ये इसका यूसेज है कि
होस्ट देन उसके बाद क्या क्या आप ऑप्शन का
यूज कर सकते हो ताकि मुझे ये पता करना है
कि ये होस्ट कमांड क्या करती है तो उसके
लिए कमांड होती है काली के
अंदर व्हाट इज
होस्ट व्हाट इज होस्ट अभी होस्ट कमांड
क्या है डीएनएस लुकअप यूटिलिटी होस्ट
कमांड क्या है एक डीएनएस लुकअप यूटिलिटी
ओके मतलब क्या है देखो जब भी आप क्या करते
हो ये मेरा ब्राउजर है फॉर एपल दिस इ आवर
ब्राउजर ब्राउजर के अंदर जो सर्च इंजन है
यह जो यूआरएल है यह एड्रेस बार है जैसे ही
मैं इसके अंदर डेनिक्स कॉ लिखा जैसे ही
मैंने . कॉ लिखा तो आपका जो ब्राउजर है
उसको नहीं पता कि इसके साथ क्या करना है
ब्राउजर डोंट डज नॉट नो व्ट टू डू विद डस
इंफॉर्मेशन इस इंफॉर्मेशन के साथ उसको
क्या करना उसको नहीं पता इस केस में ओके
इस केस में आपका आता है डीएनएस इस केस में
क्या आता है आपका डीएनएस आता है अब डीएनएस
क्या करता है डीएनएस होता है आपका डोमेन
नेम सिस्टम ठीक है डिस क्या करता है आपका
आपके डोमेन नेम को आईपी एड्रेस के अंदर
रिजॉल्व करता है मतलब इस डीएनएस नेम के
अकॉर्डिंग जो आईपी एड्रेस होगा सर्वर के
अंदर जो स्टोर किया होगा इंडेक्स करके वो
रिजॉल्व करके वापस ब्राउजर को दे देगा तो
अभी मैंने क्या किया कि जैसे de.com लिखा
तो f.com लिखते ही ओके आपका ब्राउजर बोलता
ओके मैं काम करता हूं इसको अपने डीएनएस
सर्वर को दे देते हैं डीएनए सर्वर इसको
क्या करेगा रिजॉल्व करके आईपी एड्रेस मेरे
को दे देगा क्योंकि जो भी वेब सर्वर्स है
य जो इंटरनेट है इंटरनेट पर जितने भी पूरा
पूरा जो इंटरनेट है वो आपके डोमेन नेम को
नहीं समझता ठीक है जितने भी सिस्टम्स होते
हैं वह आपके आईपी एड्रेस के द्वारा ही
जाने जाते हैं विदाउट आईपी एड्रेस आप किसी
भी चीज को सर्च नहीं कर सकते इसलिए क्या
है कि यह सिर्फ ह्यूमन रीडेबल है क्योंकि
हम आईपी एड्रेस याद नहीं रख सकते नंबर
ह्यूमन माइंड नहीं याद रख सकता लेकिन हम
यह जो इंग्लिश है जो नेम्स है उनको याद रख
सकते हैं इसलिए ऐसा सिस्टम है इसके बीच
में डीएनएस है तो क्या क्या करेगा डीएनएस
जब भी इस एड्रेस में हमने क्या किया f.com
टाइप किया तो इसने क्या किया डीएनएस लुक
अप इसने लुक अप किया कि ओके इसके अगेंस्ट
कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस है अब ये लुकअप कहां
पर करेगा इस मशीन के अंदर जो मेरी इंटरनेट
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर के लिए जो डीएनएस सेट
किया गया है कंफिल किया है गया है जो
डीएनएस सर्वर कंफिल किया गया है उसके थ्रू
डीएनएस लुक अप करेगा उसके थ्रू क्या करेगा
डीएनएस लुक अप करेगा सबका अपना अलग-अलग
होगा डिपेंड्स ऑन योर आईएसपी या डिपेंड्स
ऑन योर इंटरनेट कनेक्शंस आपका हो सकता है
कि लोकल डीएनएस आप मशीन के थ्रू भी यूज
करके देन उसके बाद राउटर्स राउटर के थ्रू
भीका आईएसपी तो डिपेंड करता है कि आप कैसे
हो तो अभी जो डीएनएस है डीएनएस क्या करता
आपने रिजॉल्व कर दिया जैसे ही डीएस ने
आईपी एड्रेस दिया देन आपका वेब ब्राउजर
क्या करता है ये जो आपका ब्राउजर्स है वो
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है गेट
रिक्वेस्ट गेट रिक्वेस्ट किसको भेजता है
आपके वेब सर्वर को और वेब सर्वर बदले में
क्या करता है रिस्पांस करता है गेट
रिक्वेस्ट करता है और उसके बदले में
रिस्पांस करेगा और आपके स्क्रीन के सामने
ये जो एचटीएमएल वेबसाइट है सीएसएस फॉर्मेट
में है जावास्क्रिप्ट को यूज किया हो गया
है ये सारी चीजें आपके सामने रिप्रेजेंट
करता है ये इस तरीके से जो सारी की सारी
चीजें हैं कुछ कपल्स ऑफ सेकंड में काम कर
रही है एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर कुछ कपल्स ऑफ
सेकंड के अंदर ये सारी की सारी चीजें आपको
काम कर रही है एवरीवन गट क्लियर किसी को
लगता है
स्टिल किसी को डाउट
है चलो तो इतना सबको पता है तो अभी मुझे
क्या करना आईपी एड्रेस फाइंड आउट करना है
तो मैं आईपी एड्रेस फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
क्या करूंगा होस्ट
एंड वेबसाइट का नाम क्या है
डेनिक्स मेरी वेबसाइट है de.com हिट एंटर
किया तो यह मेरा क्या है आईपी एड्रेस है
डेनिक्स का
15713 ओके एंड दिस इ योर मेल एड्रेस mx1
hostinger.com mx2 hostinger.com यह मेरे
वेब सर्वर का एड्रेस है ठीक है ये
इंफॉर्मेशन हमने पता कर ले कि जो जो
वेबसाइट है इसका आईपी एड्रेस अब हमारे पास
आईपी एड्रेस है एक और चीज है यहां पर कई
बार कुछ ऐसी वेबसाइट होगी यहां पर आपको एक
से ज्यादा आईपी एड्रेस देखने को मिलेंगे
एक से ज्यादा आईपी एड्रेस देखने को
मिलेंगे अगर आपको एक से ज्यादा आईपी
एड्रेस देखने को मिलते हैं तो समझ लेना कि
जो आपकी वेबसाइट है वह बिहाइंड फायरवॉल या
प्रॉक्सी है किसी भी सर्विस के द्वारा
उसको प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए उसके किसी
फायर वाल के पीछे छुपाया गया है अब ऐसा
केस भी हो सकता है तो अग मल्टीपल आईपी
एड्रेस है तो ऐसा ही केस है अब दूसरी चीज
क्या कर सकते हो आपके पास वेबसाइट है आपके
पास क्या है वेबसाइट है अभी दूसरी चीज
क्या करना है कि जो वेबसाइट है इसको
कंपलीटली आपको स्क्रॉल करना है स्क्रॉल
करके हर एक लिंक को क्लिक करके देखना है
पूरी वेबसाइट को फाइंड आउट करना है कि
यहां पर कोई इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन तो
नहीं है फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे कि किसी का नाम
किसी की ईमेल आईडी कंपनी की ईमेल आईडी या
कंपनी की ईमेल आईडी अगर मिल रही है तो
उसका पैटर्न क्या है उसका
youtube.com दिस इ द पैटर्न ऑफ de.com की
वो ईमेल कैसे सेट करती है क्लाइंट के लिए
फर्द आपको क्या करना है जैसे कि कांटेक्ट
अस प मैंने क्लिक किया तो यहां पर आप देख
सकते
ग्रुप का नाम ओपनिंग हाउस तो और बहुत सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको यहां पर देखने को मिल
सकती है तो आपको कंपलीटली क्या करना है
पूरी वेबसाइट को स्क्रोल डाउन करके देखना
है एक एक लिंक को कि क्या क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
मेरे लिए वैल्युएबल है एक चीज यह करनी है
दूसरा मैंने आपको क्या बताया था जब
वेबसाइट की बात है तो उसमें हमें दो
इंपोर्टेंट फाइल्स हम फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं दो इंपोर्टेंट फाइल्स सबसे
पहली कौन सी है क्या करेंगे हम . कॉ
फक्ड कॉ
रोबोट्स डटी एक्सटी फाइल में फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करूंगा ट एंटर किया मैंने
दिस इ रोट फाइल ऑफ डेनिक्स
यहा यूजर एजेंट अला यूजर एजेंट स्टार मतलब
सभी क्रॉलर क्रॉल कर सकते हैं डिस अलाव
क्या इसके लिए देखो डब्ल्यूपी कंटेंट
अपलोड लॉग्स दिस वन डिस अलाव यू आर नॉट
अलाउड डब्ल्यूपी एडमिन नॉट अलाउड अला क्या
डप एडमिन एडमिन ए पीएपी ये अलाउड है तो और
ऊपर से यहां पर क्या है साइट मैप की
इंफॉर्मेशन है मतलब आपको क्या करना है
सबसे पहले फाइंड आउट उसके बाद जो सबसे
पहली जो फाइल है आपको फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करनी है वो कौन सी है आपकी
robot.txt सेकंड फाइल जो आप फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करोगे वो कौन सी है साइ m
एकए अब यहां पर आप कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन देखने
को मिले कि आप इसको फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हो जैसे कि मैं इसको अगर
क्लिक करता हूं
अ यह रहा
हिट
एंटर दिस इ द एडमिन पिन ठीक है यह डेफ
इसका मतलब चीज भी है तो मैं इसको काम नहीं
कर रहा हूं फरदर बस आपके सिखाने के लिए आप
टेस्टिंग के लिए चेक कर सकते
हो यह
रहा
जोन ट्रांसफर मड
कॉडजी जोफर मड कॉ या रजी है कुछ एक ऐसी
वेबसाइट है मुझे चेक कर लीजिए मैंने कहीं
पर उसको लिखा
था डॉट
मी ओके ब्राउजर बड़ा कर देते हैं कोई इशू
नहीं है
वेट
वेट ओके चलो अभ यह ओपन नहीं हो रहा व्ट
एवर रीजन कोई इशू नहीं है लेकिन क्या कर
सकते हैं इसको भी हम क्या कर सकते इसका
आईपी एड्रेस चेक कर सकते हैं कैसे करेंगे
देखो
होस्ट
होस्ट जन
डॉट मी फट एंटर य इसका आईपी एड्रेस है
516101 यह इसके मेल सर्वर्स की डिटेल्स है
ओके तो जोफर ड मी अब इसकी भी इंफॉर्मेशन
आप क्या कर सकते फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
कर सकते हो अगर मिलेगी तो
चलो चलिए एक वेबसाइट है अभी इसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं उस ड पीएचपी है कोई इशू
नहीं एंड जोन ट्रांसफर डॉट मी है इसके
रोबट डटी एक्सटी फाइल फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश
करेंगे डीजी निंजा है कंट्रोल
व नो मतलब य पर इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को नहीं
मिल रही एक
मिनट नो इन्होंने हाइड किया हुआ है
ओके इन्होंने हाइड किया हुआ तो इस तरीके
से क्या कर सकते हो आप किसी भी वेबसाइट की
रोबोट टीटी फाइल चेक कर सकते हो दूसरी
डेनिक्स की वेबसाइट है जैसे कि मैंने क्या
किया था अभी थोड़ी देर पहले क्या है चेक
किया था तो अभी फिर से मैं चेक करता हूं
अभी साइ m ड एक्स फाइल दूसरी फाइल क्या
चेक करोगे आप साइ मैप एक्स फाइल वहां पर
कुछ ऐसी हाइड इंफॉर्मेशन तो नहीं है जो
वेबसाइट के ऊपर नहीं है जिसको हाइड करके
रखा हुआ है और जो नहीं होनी चाहिए ओके जो
नहीं होनी चाहिए तो
हो सकता है अभी
देखो डेफ की भी क्या है यहां पर साइ मैप
एक्स फाइल अवेलेबल है अब यहां पर देखिए
मैं इस पर कहीं पर भी लिंक क्लिक करता हूं
जैसे कि यह रहा यूजर वनड देखिए रहा यहां
पर फिर मैं क्या करता हूं एटीपीएस डेफ थर
सुपर जीनियस या डेफ gmail.com देखो ऑथर ये
रहा यहां पर क्या आपको क्या देखने को मिल
रहा है यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं
कुछ आर्टिकल्स देखने को मिल रहे हैं
नॉर्मल आपको देखने को नहीं मिल रहे थे
लेकिन यहां पर क्या आपको आर्टिकल देखने को
मिल रहे
हैं अब जैसे कि मैं बैक बैक करता हूं फिर
से और भी कुछ इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिलती है जैसे कि ये रहा साइट मै
पोस्ट एक्सल डॉट अभी देखो ए गुड कैरियर इन
इंडिया व्हाट एवर देखिए
यह ब्लॉग्स है तो इस तरीके से आपको साइ
मैप एक् फाइल में भी साइट मैप देखने को
मिल सकता है कई बार यहां पर आपको
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल जाती
है जो वेबसाइट के अंदर नहीं होनी चाहिए
लेकिन बाय मिस्टेक रह जाती है किसी भी
कारण से इग्नोर की वजह से या नॉलेज ना
होने की वजह से या सारी वजह से तो आई होप
कि यह सब समझ में आ गया होगा कि आपको
क्या-क्या चेक करना है आईपी एड्रेस सबसे
पहले हम पता करने की कोशिश करेंगे उसके
बाद हम क्या करेंगे उसकी हुई फॉर्मेशन पता
करेंगे क्या करेंगे उसकी हुज इंफॉर्मेशन
अब हुज इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे पता करते हैं किसी
को पता
है मैं सिंपली क्या करता हूं यह रहा इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं
इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं यह रहा अब य हुज
लिखता
हूं सिंपली कंट्रोल शि
प्लस य रहा ड कॉ य पर क्लिक
किया यहां पर ये देखिए फाइंड ए डोमेन यहां
पर हम क्या डोमेन नेम
लिखेंगे डेक्ड
कॉ सिंपली सर्च किया हु इज लुक अप करेंगे
य पर हमने जैसे हु इज लुक अप किया यहां पर
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलेगी यह
रहा
फनेट ओके ओके ऊपर करना था
यह रहा डोमेन क्या है fx.com रजिस्ट्रार
कौन है की स्ट्रीम्स जीएमबीएच जो भी है
रजिस्टर्ड ऑन 115 2023 एक्सपायर्स ऑन
11525 अपडेटेड ऑन 18624 स्टेटस क्या है
क्लाइंट ट्रांसफर प्रोहिबिटेड नेम सर्वर
कौन-कौन से हैं यह रहे दो नेम सर्वर ऊपर
से क्या है क्लाउड फेयर की सर्विस यूज कर
रही हैं अब रेजिस्टेंट कांटेक्ट ऑन द बीफ
ऑफ डेनिक्स ओनर नाम नहीं है उनका
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की डिटेल नहीं है अब यह सारी
डिटेल्स क्या है हाइड की हुई है किसके
द्वारा आपके क्लाउड फेयर के द्वारा मतलब
यह आपको एक्सपोज नहीं करना चाहती
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव कांटेक्ट डिटेल्स भी हाइड
की गई है यू कांट डू एनीथिंग टेक्निकल
कांटेक्ट कोई इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिल रही है नो बिलिंग डिटेल्स यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है अभ
ये देखि यहां पर कुछ भी रि सीटी सेम वही
चीज है तो आप इस
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो किसी भी
वेबसाइट के बारे में अभी और इसको मैं जूम
कर देता हूं आप लोगों के लिए यह रहा सबको
दिखाई दे रहा य
रहा यस हु इज डेटाबेस
से यस हम कमांड से भी कर सकते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं क्या करता हूं इसको
क्लोज करता हूं अभी मुझे कमांड से करना तो
कमांड से भी कर सकते हैं हु इजन कॉ टटर
देखिए सेम इंफॉर्मेशन आपको य पर देखने
देखिए स्क्रोल अप स्क्रॉल
अप यह
रहा डोमेन नेम डेफ कॉ रजिस्ट्री डोमेन
आईडी यह मेंशन की ग रजिस्ट्रार वज सर्वर
दिस वन रजिस्ट्रार यूआरएल दिस वन अपडेटेड
ऑन सोन सो डेट क्रिएशन डेट सोन सो डेट
रजिस्ट्री एक्सपायर डेट सोन सो डेट
रजिस्ट्रार सोन सो नेम रजिस्ट्रार आईडी
296 एनी कांटेक्ट डिटेल्स ये सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको इसके अंदर भी देखना है
नेम सर्वर्स nsc.com
nsc.com यह सारी नेम सर्वर्स की डिटेल्स
है डीएनएस सेक अनसाइंड डीएनएस सिक्योरिटी
अनसाइंड ओके देन यूज ऑफ आई कैन मतलब बहुत
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी
इसके अंदर तो इस कमांड की हेल्प से भी देख
सकते हो जैसे एक और वेबसाइट है चलो दूसरी
वेबसाइट के बारे में पता करते हैं हम हु
इज जोन
ट्रांसफर डॉट मी देखो यह इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिल रही
है चाहे प से करो वेब से करो चाहे आप ऐसे
कीजिए सेम इंफॉर्मेशन देखो जोन ट्रांसफर ड
मय एक प्रैक्टिस के लिए वेबसाइट है जोन
ट्रांसफर की जो ऑफिशियल है रजिस्टर डोमेन
अपडेटेड नोन
सो यह आईडी है डोमेन स्टेटस है देन उसके
बाद यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिलेगी एडमिन नेम यह है एडमिन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्टेट पिन अगर अवेलेबल है तो
यह रही नेम सर्वर है एनएस जटी ए2 डीजी ड
निंजा डीजी ड निंजा अनसा यह सारी चीज इसके
अंदर मेंशन है तो सबको समझ में आ गया कि
कैसे आपको अप्रोच करनी है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के लिए एवरीवन गट क्लियर आईपी
एड्रेस की इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास मिल गी ईज
इंफॉर्मेशन आपने पता कर ली नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट अभी हम करते हैं गल हैकिंग
डेटाबेस के बारे में कि हम ग डकिंग कैसे
करेंगे ग डकिंग हम कैसे करेंगे तो यहां तक
किसी का कोई डाउट है तो पूछ सकता
है एनी वन हैव एनी
डाउट एवरीवन क्लियर
चलो अच्छी बात
है हां कर सकते हो कर सकते हो अभी पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग चल रही
है कुछ नहीं या तो हाइड की हुई robot.txt
फाइल
भी अगर नहीं है तो आपका जो वेब क्रॉलर है
वो अपनी मर्जी से कुछ भी क्रॉल कर सकता
है मेनली है कि अगर एडमिंस की डिटेल्स
मिलती है कांटेक्ट या ऑफिशल मेल आईडी
मिलती है मतलब जिससे क्या कर सकते हो आप
हुज के बेस पर कि एक तो आईडिया होगा किसकी
सर्विस वो यूज कर रहे हैं और दूसरी क्या
है कि आपको ये आईडिया होगा कि ऑफिशियल मेल
टाइप किस टाइप से यूज कर रहे हैं और
एड्रेस होगा तो आप क्या कर सकते हो थोड़ी
सी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग ट्राई कर सकते हो
ऑफिशल कांटेक्ट नंबर्स होंगे तो और फर्द
आप एनिमेशन में आपकी हेल्प करेंगे फर्द
टैक्स रोकर नेम बनाने
में आपको बताया तो था अभी एक स्लाइड में
विनोद मैंने आपको बताया था स्लाइड में शो
किया था कि व्हाट टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन जो
चीज आपको अलाव है वेबसाइट पे बेसिकली आपको
क्या है साइट मैप में दिखाया था कि
फॉरवर्ड स्ल के बाद डायरेक्टरी सब
डायरेक्टरी उस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी
या कोई पेज छुपा हो सकता है जो आपके लिए
एक्सपोज नहीं है नॉर्मल ब्राउजर के लिए
लेकिन कंपनी के लिए तो है वह सारी
चीजें जो इंफॉर्मेशन होस्ट कमांड को दी जा
रही है तो वही इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड
कर र
है डिपेंड करता है कि प्रॉक्सी यूज कर रहे
नहीं कर रहे
चलो अभी बात करते हैं हम ग डकिंग करते तो
देखिए एक नॉर्मल है यह अपना मैं ग ओपन
करता हूं
फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैंने फाइंड आउट किया
स्टे साइन आउट फर एपल मैंने फाइंड आउट
किया जैसे
कि कुछ भी नाम फॉर एजाम पल
बेस्ट
पीसी यह आपका नॉर्मल ब्राउजर है यह आपका
नॉर्मल सर्च रिजल्ट है य आपके नर्मल सर्च
अब इन्ही रिजल्ट को मैं एडवांस तरीके से
कैसे यूज कर सकता हूं तो कुछ तरीके हैं
जिनको हम क्या कर ड बोलते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल जैसे मुझे करना है साइट य मैं
जूम कर देता हूं आप लोगों के
लिए ये रहा साइट कॉलन देन उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं स्टार वाइल्ड कार्ड ड कॉ कि
जितनी भी ड कॉ वेबसाइट है यह कीवर्ड्स है
जितनी भी ड कॉ वेबसाइट है इन
यूआरएल यूआरएल में आपको क्या देखना है इन
यूआरएल मैं बात करता हूं
इंडिया ओके अभी मैं जो सर्च क्यूरी है
मेरी यह है साइट कौन सी चाहिए मुझे ड कॉ
की सभी साइट और जिनके इन यूआरएल यूआरएल
में आप क्या फाइंड आउट करना चाह रहे हो
इंडिया सिंपली मैं क्या करता हूं सर्च
देखिए अभी मेरा सर्च रिजल्ट क्या है नेशनल
पोर्टल ऑफ इंडिया इंडिया टूरिजम होटल
टेरिस्ट और रेस्टोरेंट्स कॉलेजेस स्कूल्स
इंडिड कॉ वेबसाइट c.in तो सारी वही
वेबसाइट है देखिए साइट जहां जहां पर उनके
यूआरएल में इंडिया में मेंशन है वह सारी
लिस्ट आउट कर दी आपके स्क्रीन के सामने
आपके ब्राउजर ने नेक्स्ट अगर मैं इसको
चेंज करता हूं ऑल डट एजुकेशन वेबसाइट डट
डीयू एजुकेशन वेबसाइट इन यूआरएल की ज अभी
यहां पर इन यरल में लिखता
हूं सी ओ आर ओ एन ए
य रहा देखिए अभी डॉट एजुकेशन वाली सारी
वेबसाइट लेकिन करोना इन यूआरएल में होना
चाहिए सारी लिस्ट आ आपके सामने लिस्ट आउट
कर दी नेक्स्ट अगर मेरी क्वेरी यह है कि
मैं फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं देखिए
साइट मैं फाइंड आउट करना चाह रहा हूं
स्टार डॉट कॉम उसके बाद फाइल टाइप फाइंड
आउट करना चाहता हूं फाइल
टाइप कुछ गिनी चुनी है जैसे कि साइट इन
यरल इनटेक्स फाइल टाइप इन टाइटल इन फाइल
टाइप मैं पीडीएफ फाइल टाइप मेरा क्या है
पीडीएफ एंड उसके बाद मैं कीवर्ड मेंशन कर
सकता हूं यहां पर कीवर्ड में मैं लिखा
मैंने
हैकिंग और हिट एंटर
देखिए एथिकल हैकिंग पीडीए पीडीएफ फाइल
टाइप होनी चाहिए लेकिन s.com वेबसाइट के
अंदर लेकिन हैकिंग कीवर्ड ये फाइंड आउट
करना चाहता हूं पीडीएफ फाइल देखिए देखो
google3 टेस्टिंग ब्लैक हैट
देखो सारी पीडीएफ फाइल है यरी ऑल आर
पीडीएफ फाइल फॉर एपल इसको मैं क्लोज करता
हूं नेक्स्ट अरे हो हो
सॉरी google.com
चलो अभी फिर से मैं सर्च की क्या थी
मेरी साइट अब क्या बदल देते हैं साइट
स्टार ड कॉम फाइल टाइप उसके बाद
पीडीएफ
देन
हैक यह रही ट एंटर किया देखिए य रहा सारी
वही बुक आ गई अगर मैं ये पता करना चाहता
हूं कि इन टाइटल अभी यूज करते हैं हम इन
टाइटल टाइटल के अंदर क्या फाइंड आउट करना
चाहता हूं मैं इंडेक्स ऑफ इंडेक्स
ऑफ देन उसके बाद इन यूआरएल इन यूआरएल मैं
क्या जाता हूं
एफटीपी इन यूरल एफटीपी एफटीपी सर्वर की
डिटेल्स आफ्टर
20 ओके ये इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करो तो हिट एंटर देखिए
ओके यके देखि इंडेक्स ऑफ मेल आर्काइव मैं
फॉर एजाम पल यह वाली देखता हूं दिखाता
आपको यह
रहा यह देखो क्लिक किया यह सारी एफटीपी
डिटेल्स देखो यहां पर इसको मैं जूम कर
देता आपके
सामने यहां पर देखोगे आप ड एक् य रहा
अभी यहां पर आपको कितनी चीज समझ में आ रही
है और कितनी नहीं आ रही वही चीज है फिर से
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं बैक करता हूं अभी
मैं डॉट
सीएसवी अभी सीएसवी फाइल में ओपन करता हूं
देखो अभी ऐसे मेंशन की हुई है ए ग्रेट वाल
ए लर्निंग गाइड कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
यूनिवर्सिटी ऑफ सोन सो देखिए इस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन है
चलो इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं तो इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो एडवांस ग
सर्च इंजन का यूज कर सकते हो जिसको हम
बोलते हैं एडवांस ग सर्च या ग डकिंग बोल
सकते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं अभी अभी मैं पता करना चाहता हूं
कि फाइल टाइप
फइल टाइप
नवी
देन डीबी अंडर स्कोर
पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड देन उसके बाद
आफ्टर
9 ओके हिट एंटर
देखिए अभी फाइल टाइप एनवी ये रहा यूजिंग
डीबी पासवर्ड ट कंटेंट हैज इंटरप्टेड गट
माय पासवर्ड सो सो कोई भी देखिए ओपन करके
देखिए ये रहा नवी फाइल्स य पर कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है एंड
नो यहां कोई इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
नहीं मिल रही तो इस तरीके से आप यूज कर
सकते हो अभी आपको कैसे पता चलेगा कि मुझे
कौन सा ग डक यूज करना है सबसे बड़ा सवाल
होगा कि सर मुझे ग डकिंग में कौन सा ग डक
यूज करना मैं कैसे करूंगा तो आपको सिंपली
क्या करना है अभी कि सिंपली आपको क्या
करना है
google2 में कौन-कौन सी चल रही है टॉप अभी
मैं आप बात करोगे फाइल पासवर्ड फाइल
कंटेनिंग पासवर्ड जैसे कि यह चल रही है
अभी 238 2024 की टॉप है आप सिंपली इसको
क्या करोगे कॉपी करोगे क्योंकि सारे डॉक्स
है आप मेरे जैसे जिनको लगता है कि इस ग डर
की या इस एडवांस कमांड की वजह से कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन या वैल्युएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है जिसकी वजह से कंपनी
में लॉस हो सकता था बाउंट मिली है तो आप
उसको क्या कर सकते ग हैकिंग डेटाबेस में
रजिस्टर करवा सकते हैं तो ये वही है अभी
मैंने इसको कॉपी
किया कॉपी एंड सिंपली मुझे यहां पर क्या
करना है ब्राउजर अंदर पेस्ट कर देना पेस्ट
एंड गो
देखिए पेस्ट एंड गो तो ओपन एसएसएस की नॉट
एक्सेप्टेड यह रहा सपोर्ट ओपन एस प्राइवेट
की फॉर्मेट टूल्स टू डील विद ओपन एस लाइक
ट क क्लासिक फॉर्मेट तोसे रिलेटेड कुछ ना
कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिली है देखो
यहां पर यह रही यह रही इंफॉर्मेशन कुछ ना
कुछ देखने को आपको मिल सकती
है यह रही की कुछ की इंफॉर्मेशन देखो यहां
पर एसस टू पब्लिक की य आप पब्लिक की है यह
भी क्या है आरएस की कमेंट
कमेंट पब्लिक की
है दिस नॉट कम तो इस तरीके से य पर क्या
है पब्लिक की मिली है तो जैसे कि अभी मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं नेक्स्ट मैं पता कर सकता
हूं वल्नरेबल सर्व यह रहा य मैं इसको कॉपी
करता हूं कॉपी एंड
पेस्ट कंट्रोल व
यह
रहा लबरेज कोहा ऑनलाइन कैटालॉग ट एंटर
किया कौन सा एचटीटीपी सर्वर है य समझ पा
रहे होग एचटीटीपी सर्वर है यह कनेक्शन इज
नॉट सिक्योर म एचटीटीपीएस नहीं है एटीटीपी
है तो य कुछ और भी इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है
तो मैं आपको जस्ट दिखा रहा हूं कि आप ग
डकिंग को कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं और नेक्स्ट
क्लास में आपको बिफोर क्लास से पहले एक
बार यह बता दूंगा कि ग डकिंग का एक टूल्स
भी होता है व पर सिर्फ आपको डोमेन इंसर्ट
करना उसके बाद मल्टीपल डकिंग के हिसाब से
अपने रिजल्ट आ जाते हैं एक टूल्स है मैंने
भी कहीं से पढ़ा था आपको जल्दी शेयर कर
दूंगा ग्रुप के अंदर मैं आपको दिखा भी
दूंगा तो आई होप ग डकिंग समझ में आया कैसे
करते हैं आप सिंपली आपको खुद से बनाने की
जरूरत नहीं है वैसे आप चाहो तो
देखो
टॉप
ग डॉक्स गिट अप ट फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो यह
र कलेक्शन लिस्ट यहां पर और क्लिक कीजिए
और यह भी यूज कर सकते हो आप यहां
पर अ जोड एक्सटी फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
एड्स जसे एड की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने
के लिए दे कलेक्शन है
य यह टॉप है यह रहे ऐसे साइट ए3 यह र
एग्जांपल डॉ कम एग्जांपल फाइल टब एक् य
जैसे कि मैंने इसको क्या किया कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल
व य
रहा कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है यूजर
डिटेल्स
देखो
कुछ देखते हैं अभी ओपन नहीं हो रही है
फाइल चूज
एप्लीकेशन
ओपन
देखो अभी कुछ हुआ नहीं ओपन मे भी
तो फाइल आपको ओपन करके देखनी होगी अभी ओपन
नहीं हुई है तो इस तरीके से आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल जाती है समझ में
आया तो इस यहां पर आप गेट हब प भी ट्राई
कर सकते हो उसके बाद आप खुद के भी बना
सकते हो ग ड क्योंकि आपके पास गिने चुने
रहते हैं देखो साइट रहता है इन यरल होता
है टेक्स्ट होता है इन टेक्स्ट होता है
फाइल टैप होता है इनटाइटल होता है तो ये
सारी चीजें हैं आप खुद से भी बना सकते हो
दूसरा नहीं तो ग हैकिंग डेटाबेस का आप यूज
कर सकते हो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए तो यहां तक का आपका प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
था एवरीवन गट
क्लियर एवरीवन गट क्लियर स्टिल एनी वन हैव
एनी डाउट्स आज की क्लास इतनी ही थी कि
आपका प्रैक्टिकल सेशन था और इससे पहले
आपका थोरेट्स था और इतना मत समझिए कि सर
ये दो तो दो या तीन चीज बताई मैं आपको एक
अप्रोच वे में बता रहा हूं मल्टीपल टूल्स
भी बताऊंगा सब फाइंडर सब लिस्टर रिकन एनजी
और आपके कुछ आपको सब डोमन से न्यूमरेशन
कैसे करने है सब डोमस फाइंड आउट कैसे करने
हैं यह भी बताऊंगा आपको मैं और देन उसके
बाद पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन कैद से एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग आएंगे और देन उसके बाद
हमारी असली फाइटिंग स्टार्ट होती है
प्रैक्टिकल की उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू
हैकिंग ही करेंगे एथिकल हैकिंग करेंगे
लैब्स के थ्रू हम कंटिन्यू सीखेंगे टाइप्स
ऑफ अटैक्स कभी आरसी कभी कमांड इंजेक्शन हो
जाएगा तो उसके थ हम सेल फिर उसे रूट सेल
और इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करेंगे एक अप्रोच वे
में
ओके ग डॉगिंग से बहुत ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल सकती है अगर आप सही से
इसको यूज करोगे दे मल्टीपल ओनली इतनी ही
नहीं है देखो नेक्स्ट पेज प पेज नंबर थ्री
पेज नंबर फोर
आप इस तरीके से फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
इंफॉर्मेशन देखो फाइल्स कंटेनिंग जसी
इंफॉर्मेशन किसी इसको आप यह वाला यूज कर
सकते हो इन यल एचटीटीपी रा फाइल देखो इन
टेक्स्ट यूजर फाइल टाइप पीएचपी इन टेक्स्ट
अकाउंट इन यरल एडमिन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
इस तरीके से आप सर्च मार्क कर सकते
हो गर में इतना ज्यादा कुछ रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है पेंटोनिक
यहां पर सर्च कर सकते हो ना आप
देखो पीएचपी के लिए सर्च कर लो यह
देखो फेटल एरर वाली चीज यह सर्च कर लो
फाइल कंटेनिंग ज नेबल सर्वर्स यह रही
सिंपली कंट्रोल
सी कंट्रोल व हिट एंटर य रहा पीएचपी
एलग लट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर
अवेलेबल ये
रहा अभी देख लो किसकी
य पता चल रहा है कैसे फाइंड आउट करना है
इ से देखो आप चीजें यूज कर कर के बना सकते
हो इसमें कुछ ज्यादा नहीं कुछ गिने चुने
कीवर्ड होते हैं साइट इन टाइटल इन यूआरएल
इन टेक्स्ट दे रहे
ऐसे मैं आप लोगों को ट्राई करता हूं एक
ऐसा लिंक देने की जिसमें आप ग डकिंग बना
बनाना सीख सकते हैं ओके
यस यस यस यस टेक एक्सपर्ट ऐसे कर सकते हो
तो आज का सेशन इतना ही था प्लीज
बताइए स्टिल किसी का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ लीजिए उसके बाद हम सेशन को एंड करेंगे
बताइए विशु मैं आपको एक
नेक्स्ट क्लास में एक सॉफ्टवेयर है एक
टूल्स है उस टूल्स को डाउनलोड करवा दूंगा
इंस्टॉल करवा दूंगा उस टूल्स में आप
सिंपली आप डोमेन इंफॉर्मेशन पुट इन करोगे
टेक्स्ट करोगे टाइप करोगे उसके बाद वो
रिजल्ट आपके उसी हिसाब से देगा को बनाने
की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी
बेसिक सिंटेक्स मालूम होने चाहिए कभी भी
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में आपको प्रोग्रामिंग
आए या ना आए आपको बेसिक सिंटेक्स आने
चाहिए पढ़ना आना चाहिए बस उतना ही होता
है हां एक और इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें मुझे आप
लोग बताइए एक और
चीज कि मैं अगर आपको मैं टास्क दूं जैसे
कि लिनक्स के लिए
तो आप उससे कर लोगे देखो नक् को मैं
करवाऊंगी आप बोर हो
जाओगे नक् को मैं करवाऊंगी इससे बढ़िया जो
मेरी प्लेलिस्ट है यहां पर य के अंदर य
मैं अपनी य चलते हैं हम डीसी जीएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल्स तो हम डीसी जीएसपी सॉरी
डेनिस अकेडमी यह रहा काली नक् फ्री
कैप्सूल कोर्स है यह फुल प्लेलिस्ट है अगर
आप आई रिक्वेस्ट कि अगर आप इसको कंप्लीट
प्लेलिस्ट को देख लोगे इस कोर्स की तो
रिक्वायरमेंट समझ लो 128 वीडियो
नहीं वन से लेकर डे वन से लेकर डे 15 तक
अगर आप इनको नेक्स्ट 10 टू 15 डेज में
कंप्लीट ले देख लोगे
तो शायद आपके लिए काफी ब काफी नहीं बहुत
ज्यादा हेल्पफुल होगा आप लोगों के लिए तो
हो जाएगा ये एज टास्क तो आप लोगों के लिए
टास्क प टास्क के तौर पर है पहली दो
वीडियो को देखना फर्स्ट डे वन और डे
टू जिसने इन वीडियो को देख लिया जिसको
क्लास एक बार देख
लीजिए तो फिर भी आगे अब अब भी आप लोगों को
कोई डाउट है तो प्लीज पूछ लीजिए नेक्स्ट ू
मिनट में आपके चैट सेक्शन को देख रहा हूं
अगर नेक्स्ट टू मिनट्स में आपका कोई भी
डाउट नहीं होगा तो हम सेशन को एंड कर
देंगे ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे
नेक्स्ट क्लास व ग्रुप चैनल पर आपको पता
चल जाएगी कब
होगी ऋषभ आईपी एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होती है किसी भी होस्ट की किसी भी सिस्टम
की उसी की हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो
किसी भी सिस्टम को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन कर सकते हो विदाउट आईपी
एड्रेस आप एक सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम के
साथ कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर
सकते देंगे सीड डोंट वरी जैसे जैसे आगे
बढ़ेंगे इस कोर्स में जितना जरूरत उतना ही
पढ़ाऊंगा
किसी का कोई डाउट है क्लास रिलेटेड प्लीज
पूछिए नहीं मेरे कोस में डीसी जीएसपी वाले
फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स में तो नहीं है
अभी के
लिए व इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
नाम अब एक तो आप ओरिजिनल नाम से नहीं हो
देखो गल ड किंग करने के बाद अगर आपको
हेल्पफुल इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है फॉर
एग्जांपल आपको कुछ ऐसी फर्मे मिलती है
किसी के पासवर्ड टीसी फाइल मिलती है
पासवर्ड फाइल या कुछ क्रेडेंशियल मिलते
हैं या कोई आपकी बकेट एस एडब्ल्यू एस की
की मिलती है एपीआई की मिलती है जो मतलब की
एक्सपोज नहीं होनी थी वो एक्सपोज हो रही
हैं तो आप उनको रिपोर्ट कर सकते हो अगर
कोई जूसी इंफॉर्मेशन है जो आपके फदर अटैक
मतलब दूसरे अटैक को परफॉर्म करने के लिए
हेल्पफुल हो सकती है तो फिर आपके लिए तब
भी हेल्पफुल हो सकता है
तो व सई चीजें मतलब क्या है कि कुछ ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन जो आपकी वेबसाइट में आप नहीं
चाहते थे किसी को पता चले लेकिन वह आपके
किसी क्रॉलर ने रिपोर्ट इंडेक्सिंग कर ली
है अपने पास रख ली है और वह हैकर्स या कोई
भी अटैकर्स
उसको गैदर कर पा रहा है और काफी हेल्पफुल
हो सकती
है ओके नोट मिल जाए नोट्स मिल जाएंगे
नहीं बकेट क्या होता है एडब्ल्यू में
बकेट्स होती हैं स्टोरेज होती है क्या
होता है कि जो क्लाउड सर्विसेस है क्लाउड
में मतलब क्या कि हर चीज के लिए क्या है
कि आपको खरीदनी पड़ेगी जैसे कि आपकी
स्टोरेज है स्टोरेज खरीदनी पड़ती बकेट की
फॉर्म्स में होते है उसमें क्या करते हो
आप अपनी इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन रखते हो
चाहे आप वेबसाइट होस्टिंग भी कर रहे हो या
कुछ ऐसी इंपोर्टेंट फाइल्स हो वो बकेट्स
की फॉर्म में स्टोर होती है अगर वह
एक्सपोज हो रही है आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
एक्सपोज हो रही है तो तब भी प्रॉब्लम
है वन लेवल वेबसाइट हाउ टू
फाइंड देखो
आपको हायर किया जाएगा अगर आप किसी कंपनी
में करोगे तो आपको वेबसाइट या टारगेट बताए
जाएंगे अरवाज बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म से वहां
से आप फाइंड आउट कीजिए और किसी भी वेबसाइट
पर रेंडम ट्राई
कीजिए बकेट एक वलने बिलिटी नहीं है बकेट
एकट
हां अगर व एक्सपोज हो जाती है तो उसमें
वनटी
है तो वी विल ट्राई कि अगर आपके ज्यादा
डाउट्स होंगे तो हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं कि
आपके डाउट सेशन जी मट रख
ले देखिए मैं हर चीज बताऊंगा एकक एनजी है
जो भी मतलब जहां जिस टूल्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट है उसको तभी कवर करू करूंगा
अगर आप पर्टिकुलर टूल्स को आज ही पढ़ने के
लिए आए हैं
तो आई कांट
से तो मैं सेशन को एंड करता हूं फिर
ओके तो काफी देर तक हो गया है आपके मुझे
लगता नहीं कोई वैलिड डाउट्स है
ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं बाय बाय टेक
केयर एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन तब तक
अपनी प्रैक्टिस कीजिए जो भी पढ़ाया है अभी
तो कुछ पढ़ाया नहीं इतना खास तो प्रैक्टिस
करने की जरूरत नहीं है लेकिन बस बने रहिए
और एक बार चीजों को ट्राई कीजिए खुद से
मैं आपको को कांसेप्ट दे रहा हूं आपको एक
रास्ता बता रहा हूं सेल्फ प्रैक्टिस कीजिए